Dr. Conner's regarding our conversation on Monday about my labs and my thyroid numbers.
My thyroid doctor asked about maybe thyroid cancer possibly reoccurring.
I want your thoughts on that. Scary. Thank you. So, um, so, well,
that person's thyroid numbers, if I recall, they had elevated TSH, over 100.
So, TSH is thyroid stimulated horrible. That's created in the, in the, um,
tuteri gland. They had depressed, reverse T3, and they had depressed T3 and depressed T4,
free T3 and free T4. Negative TPO antibodies, negative thyroid globulin antibodies.
That is the picture-perfect diagnostic scenario of primary hypothyroidism.
So, it's, it would be very rare for a person with thyroid cancer who have any abnormalities
in their thyroid numbers. Either their T3, T4 typically thyroid cancer doesn't affect T3 and T4,
but thyroid cancer does not affect TSH. So, when you have elevated TSH,
depressed T3, free T3, depressed free T4, negative antibodies.
That is a picture-perfect example of primary hypothyroidism.
There's always that one in a million chance that, you know, it could be something else,
and to get, if you want to, rule it out, rule it out, get a scan an MRI of the thyroid gland,
then you could rule it out. Typically, if cancer, thyroid gland was reoccurring,
you would see, you know, you would, you would have other palpatory findings as well,
but if you want to be careful in ruling out, I would, I would not say those numbers are indicative
of thyroid cancer returning based upon the numbers. Does it mean that something might not be going on,
but I wouldn't look at that to even cross my mind that, that is, you know,
a ominous side of thyroid cancer. There's lots of standard blood work and, you know,
specific to an organ or something like that blood work that you could run that gives you ominous
suns, you know, like it's not diagnostic of anything, but it's an ominous side kind of gives you
clues. So, for instance, you know, some ominous signs in your complete metabolic panel would be,
wow, my cholesterol has always run about 205 to 220, and I was really excited because I ran my
complete metabolic panel, my cholesterol was down to 115.
Sorry, but that's not, that's the band sign. So, if you have your cholesterol plummet,
so if the person wasn't taking lipitor or any say like that, well, even if you're taking lipitor,
it shouldn't have 100 points. So, but having low cholesterol isn't ominous sign.
Of course, you're 13-year-old cousin who goes and doesn't complete metabolic panel and maybe they
have cholesterol of 115 that can be their normal cholesterol. But if your normal cholesterol is 180 to,
you know, 220 or something like that, and you go and you run it and it's down in the low 100,
that's an ominous sign of liver cancer. Another ominous sign in standard blood work would be
depressed or changes in your liver function tests like your alkaline phosphatase, your AST,
your ALP, your albumin, your globulin levels, those are just different ominous signs. They're not
they're not diagnostic of anything specific without looking at other things, but typically with
the thyroid, the person isn't going to have abnormal thyroid levels and then the person goes
to the doctor goes, well, this could be a sign of cancer. We need to investigate. No, the signs of
cancer with the thyroid will be palpitory findings, would be a mass, would be something we need to do
an ultrasound done and then do a scan of and then do a biopsy of. So, that's would be my take on that.